soaring temperatures high humidity the
first heat wave of the year has
descended on Greece in a capital offense
the easing of the lockdown did little to
tempt people onto its streets instead it
was the beaches that many drifted
towards travel across the mainland will
be allowed from Monday but it will be
another week after that before its
islands will allow visitors again slowly
the country continues to open up its
churches unlock their doors to the
faithful for the first time in two
months I'm taking precautions because
they ordered it not so much because I'm
afraid I always kept distancing and kept
apart from my grandchildren in the UK
the lockdown has been extended until at
least the end of June
the warmer weather has tempted few onto
the beaches here confusion over the
government's new guidelines remains as
well as efforts to reopen schools while
government ministers and scientists
attempt to calm fears that allowing
children back could cause infections to
rise it does seem from what we know now
that children are less capable of
spreading it even if they get the
infection and certainly are at very low
risk of getting killing from the disease
from one country trying to emerge from
lockdown to another still in
self-isolation Russia has the world's
second fastest rate of new infections
behind the United States with Moscow the
epicenter of its epidemic more than 9700
new cases were recorded on Sunday the
number of deaths from covered 19 has now
surpassed 2600 much lower compared to
the US UK and Italy but questions still
remain about how Russia is registering
those deaths and whether it's
attributing them to other causes so
Anita Jaeger al Jazeera